"THE FIVE."
>> PUTIN WAS BANKING ON DANA
BEING SPLIT.
NATO HAS NEVER, NEVER BEEN
UNITED THAT IT IS TODAY.
POLLUTANT IS GETTING THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT HE INTENDED AS
A CONSEQUENCE OF GOING INTO
UKRAINE.
>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN AT AN
EMERGENCY NATO SUMMIT TRYING TO
RATCHET UP PRESSURE ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
FINANCING MORE SANCTIONS AGAINST
RUSSIA.
THE PRESIDENT LOSING HIS TEMPER
WHEN PRESSED IF HE COULD'VE DONE
MORE.
>> IT YOU THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN
WILL ALTER COURSE BASED ON THE
ACTION YOU'VE TAKEN?
>> REMEMBER IF YOU COVER ME FROM
THE BEGINNING, I DID NOT SAY
THAT THE SANCTIONS WOULD DETER
HIM.
SANCTIONS NEVER DETERRED.
YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT THAT.
SANCTIONS NEVER DETER.
THE MAIN USE OF SANCTIONS, THE
MAINTENANCE OF SANCTIONS, THE
INCREASING THE PAIN.
STICKER DO YOU BELIEVE WILL HAVE
AN IMPACT?
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
YOU'RE PLAYING A GAME WITH ME.
THE ANSWER IS NO.
THE REASON I ASK FOR MEETING, WE
HAVE TO STAY FULLY, TOTALLY
THOROUGHLY UNITED.
>> Greg: UKRAINE SAYS IT BLEW
UP A RUSSIAN SHIP VENICE SLOWLY
PUSHING BACK RUSSIAN FORCES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN APPEARING TO DRY
REDLINE ON WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
FOR THE U.S. AND NATO TO
DIRECTLY RESPOND TO RUSSIA.
>> CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
INTELLIGENCE DATA.
WE WOULD RESPOND.
WE WOULD RESPOND IF HE USES IT.
THE NATURE OF THIS RESPONSE
WOULD DEPEND ON THE NATURE OF
THE USE.
>> Greg: GEORGE, WHAT DOES
DANA THINK ABOUT IT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Judge Jeanine: DANA HAS
BEEN ON TELEVISION ALL DAY AND
SHE HAS BEEN WONDERFUL.
YOU SHOULD GO TO DANA RIGHT AWAY
AND THEN COME BACK TO ME.
>> Greg: YOU SAID SOMETHING
TODAY.
I WAS NODDING IN AGREEMENT.
I WAS LIKE, WHY DID HE ANSWER
THAT QUESTION ABOUT 2020 FARMER?
THEN THE SECOND PART WHICH IS
THAT HE LIED.
HE BROUGHT UP THE HOAX WHICH IS
BEEN DEBUNKED.
HE SAID POLICE OFFICERS DIED ON
JANUARY 6.
NO.
ANYWAY.
HE WAS OKAY.
>> Dana: HE GOES OVER THERE
FOR THE EMERGENCY MEETING.
IT'S GOOD THAT HE WENT.
THEY HAVE THIS UNITY.
HE SAID NATO IS UNIFIED.
WE GET IT.
MR. PRESIDENT, WE DON'T NEED TO
HEAR IT AGAIN UNLESS SOMETHING
HAPPENS.
THEN HE ONLY TAKES FOUR OR FIVE
QUESTIONS.
THEN HE GOES TO THE GERMAN
PAPER.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN AMERICAN
POLITICS, TAKES THE QUESTION AND
IT'S ABOUT, WILL YOU RUN IN
2024?
YOU CAN SAY I AM TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
2024 IS A LONG WAY AWAY.
I SAID I'M GOING TO RUN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
THEN HE SAID I HAD TO RUN AND
THEN HE HAD TO GO RETREAD
THROUGH ALL BACKGROUND.
I WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
USE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ONE
MORE QUESTION ON THE RELEVANT
POINT.
I WOULD NOT HAVE DONE IT ON
FOREIGN SOIL BUT HE DID.
OKAY, FINE.
I ALSO THOUGHT OF ALL THESE
REPORTERS COMPLETELY INVESTED.
I THINK THE COVERAGE OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TERMS OF
WHAT THEY ARE DOING HAS BEEN
PRETTY GOOD.
WITH HIS MESSAGING, THEIR
MESSAGING IS SO TIMID.
YOU'RE LEFT WONDERING WHAT IS
THE MISSION?
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WHAT WE WANT TO HAVE HAPPENED?
WHAT IS THE END GOAL?
DID YOU DISCUSS IT?
THESE THINGS THAT MAYBE WE WILL
LEARN IN THE COMING DAYS AND THE
CLOSED-DOOR MEETINGS MAYBE THEY
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS BUT IF I
WAS ZELENSKYY, I WOULD WATCH
THAT AND SAID THEY WANT ME TO
GIVE THE PRESS CONFERENCE
QUESTION LIKE HE COULD'VE
ANSWERED IT A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
HOW DID I DO?
>> Judge Jeanine: GREAT JOB.
ONE OF THE RULES OF
DANA PERINO'S VISIT TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES AS YOU GO THERE WITH
THE INTENT OF ANNOUNCING
SOMETHING, DELIVERING SOMETHING.
MORE TO THE SAY THAT WAS
DIFFERENT?
WHAT HE SAID WAS SO SIMILAR TO
WHAT HE SAID BEFORE.
HE BASICALLY SAID WERE GOING TO
RESPOND TO CHEMICAL WEAPONS
DEPENDING ON HOW AND HOW MUCH
THEY USE.
IT WAS THIS KIND OF VEIN.
VAPID,
VACUOUS.
IT WASN'T LIKE RONALD REAGAN.
HERE'S WHAT WE GOT TO DO.
WE WIN, THEY LOSE.
OR UKRAINE WINGS, THEY LOSE BUT
IT'S CLEAR THAT UKRAINE IS IN A
POSITION -- RUSSIA IS STUMPED.
THEY ARE EMBARRASSED IN FRONT OF
THE WORLD.
THEY HIT APPARENTLY A RUSSIAN
SHIP IN THE SEA.
THE QUESTION IS HOW ARE WE GOING
TO DO THIS THROUGHOUT RUSSIA
BACKS OFF?
IS ZELENSKYY GOING TO BE FORCED
INTO THE IDEA THAT JUST GIVE
RUSSIAN WHAT THEY ALREADY HAVE
LOTS LET BYGONES BE BYGONES.
NO.
UKRAINE '94 WAS TOLD IF YOU GIVE
UP YOUR NUKES, WE'LL TAKE CARE
OF YOU.
WE'LL PROTECT YOU.
THEY NEVER TODAY.
AND ZELENSKYY IS SAYING I DON'T
WANT TO BE PART OF NATO.
I WANT TO BE PART OF THE GROUP.
UNITED STATES, THE U.K., WHERE I
AM PROTECTED.
SOME KIND OF TREATY WHERE I AM
PROTECTED.
THAT'S ALL I WANT.
AT THIS POINT WHAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT IS THIS GUY'S
PROBABLY GOING TO END THIS.
I THINK ZELENSKYY CAN DEFENDING
ON WHAT WERE GIVING -- DEPENDING
ON WHAT WE ARE GIVING HIM.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THE POINT TO
PUTIN, YOU'RE OUT.
>> Greg: JESSE, I WANT TO PLAY
SOME SOUND ON TAPE, WE CALL THAT
SOT AND THE TV BUSINESS.
TALKING ABOUT HOW RUSSIANS
AREN'T COMMUNICATING WITH OUR
ADMINISTRATION.
STICKLEY OF TRIED ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS TO CONNECT SECRETARY
AUSTIN WITH HIS COUNTERPART.
CHAIRMAN MILLEY HAS ALSO TRIED
TO CONNECT WITH HIS COUNTERPART.
WE HAVE MADE MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS.
THEY'VE NOT ANSWERED.
THEY HAVE DECLINED TO TAKE THESE
CALLS.
>> Greg: I WOULD LIKE TO QUOTE
RIGHT WINGER TREVOR NOAH, THIS
WOULD NEVER HAPPEN UNDER TRUMP.
THEY ANSWERED HIS CALLS.
DOES THIS MATTER?
DO WE NEED TO TALK TO THAT SIDE?
ARE WE GETTING OUR INFORMATION
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE?
>> Jesse: THERE'S NOTHING MORE
HUMILIATING WHEN THE PHONE CALL
GO STRAIGHT TO VOICE MAIL.
WHETHER YOU'RE A GUY CALLING A
GIRL, WHERE THEY OR SOMEONE
THAT'S IN SAILS.
IF SOMEONE DOESN'T PICK UP YOUR
CALL, THAT'S REALLY, REALLY BAD.
SO YES, THAT'S A PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU DO AN INTERVIEW AND
THEN AFTER IT'S OVER YOU THINK
GOD, WHY DID I SAY IT LIKE THAT?
THAT'S HOW BIDEN MUST BE
THINKING.
THEY ASKED HIM.
THIS IS WHERE PRESIDENTS REALLY
GET THEIR CHANCE TO MAKE A HUGE
STATEMENT.
IF RUSSIA LAUNCHES A CHEMICAL
ATTACK, WHAT WILL THE U.S.
RESPONSE BE?
THESE ARE THE KIND OF MOMENTS
THAT ARE MADE FOR PRESIDENTIAL
POLITICS.
HERE IN BRUSSELS.
THERE'S A WAR.
RUSSIA IS ABOUT TO DO SOMETHING.
BIDEN MUMBLES SOMETHING ABOUT
OH, YOU KNOW.
JOE BIDEN, SPEAK.
THAT WAS YOUR MOMENT TO SHINE IN
EUROPE, TO SAY SOMETHING THAT
MAKES EVERYBODY PROUD AND BE
CLEAR.
THEN THEY SAID IF ZELENSKYY
WANTS TO NEGOTIATE SOME
TERRITORIAL -- HE GOES, YOU KNOW
WHAT.
IF ZELENSKYY WANTS TO LET THE
RUSSIANS HAVE THE EAST, THAT'S
UP TO ZELENSKYY.
WHAT KIND OF ANSWER IS THAT?
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO SAY NO!
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
LITTLE BACKBONE.
THEN HE LEAVES THE PRESS
CONFERENCE AFTER A MINUTE OR TWO
AND EVERYONE STARTS SCREAMING.
ONE MORE QUESTION, OKAY.
THEN HE LOSES HIS TEMPER AND HE
SAYS THE SANCTIONS WERE NEVER A
DETERRENT.
I NEVER SAID THAT.
WELL, EVERYBODY ELSE IN YOUR
ADMIN INITIATION SAID IT.
KAMALA, SULLIVAN, CURVY, THEY
ALL SAID IT.
THEY ARE NOT ON THE SAME PAGE
AND THEN HE SAYS NATO IS
UNIFIED.
SO WHAT IF NATO IS UNIFIED.
UKRAINE IS GETTING SWALLOWED UP
WHOLE.
YOU CAN HAVE NO UKRAINE BUT AS
LONG AS NATO IS UNIFIED.
ZELENSKYY COULD BE DEAD.
NATO IS UNIFIED.
SO WHAT.
THIS IS EMBARRASSING, ESPECIALLY
WHEN HE WAS WALKING.
DID YOU SEE HOW THEY WERE
GUIDING HIM LIKE AN USHER TAKES
A PERSON TO THEIR SEAT WHEN THE
LIGHT STARTED BLINKING BEFORE
INTERMISSION?
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
COME ON.
THEN HE SAYS THERE COULD BE SOME
FAMINE.
WE KNOW THERE'S A RECESSION
COMING IN AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THERE IS NO URGENCY.
THERE'S NO URGENCY TO STOP THIS
WAR.
HE'S LIKE, WE WILL DO A COUPLE
MORE SANCTIONS.
WE'LL SANCTION THIS GUY AND THAT
GUY.
COME ON.
THIS IS MUCH, MUCH MORE INTENSE.
>> Greg: JESSICA, YOU WERE
SAYING HOW EMBARRASSED YOU WERE
TO BE AN AMERICAN ON HER
JOE BIDEN AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M KIDDING.
I'M GLAD WE COORDINATED TODAY.
DO YOU CARE TO RESPOND TO JESSE?
COULD YOU ARGUE THAT BIDEN IS
TRYING TO PORTRAY A SENSE OF
CALM AS OPPOSED TO URGENCY?
WOULD?
WOULD IT BE THAT HIS STRATEGY?
>> Jessica: I COULD ARGUE
THAT.
I COULD ALSO ARGUE THAT JESSE'S
PERCEPTION OF THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS NOT IN SYNC WITH
WHAT HOW I WAS VIEWING IT OR A
LOT OF AMERICANS.
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD.
BIDEN DID HAVE REAL
DELIVERABLES.
HE SAID OUT LOUD I WANT RUSSIA
OUT OVER THE G20.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
WHEN YOU SAY RUSSIA SHOULD BE
OUT.
OF BUILDING A NEW HUMANITARIAN
AID, TAKING 100,000 REFUGEES.
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS STILL NOT
ENOUGH BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT THEY
KNOW IT'S A PROBLEM.
THERE'S ANOTHER 320 MILLION WHAT
THEY ARE CALLING SOCIETAL
RESILIENCE, TO MAKE SURE THE
MEDIA CAN KEEP FUNCTIONING HOW
WE ARE SUPPORTING LGBTQ PEOPLE
IN UKRAINE, ET CETERA.
THOSE FEEL LIKE REAL
DELIVERABLES TO ME.
SEE SIX, JESSICA.
>> Dana: BUT WE ARE NOT ENDING
THE WAR.
>> Jesse: ON THE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS FRONT, IT'S A BIG MOMENT
PRETTY THINK BACK TO ONE OF THE
BIGGEST FOREIGN POLICY BLUNDERS
OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS
THE SYRIA REDLINE ADVISED
MS. GET HIS -- GETTING HIS OWN
REDLINE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE AND I AM
SURE BORIS JOHNSON WILL BE FULLY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE LINE CAN
BE REALLY, REALLY SMALL.
WHENEVER THEY DO, IF THERE'S A
CHEMICAL WEAPON ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE, WE WILL RESPOND TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT OF WHAT NATO CAN
DO.
BUT I KNOW YOU WANT TO DISAGREE
WITH ME.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID HE SAY
ABOUT THE CHEMICAL RESPONSE?
WHAT DID HE SAY?
I DON'T REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID.
>> Jessica: HE SAID THERE WILL
BE A RESPONSE.
>> Jesse: JESSICA, IT WAS
GOBBLEDYGOOK.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE NATURE
OF OUR RESPONSE DEPENDS ON THE
NATURE OF VIEW.
THE OTHER THING HE SAID WAS THEY
WERE GOING TO GIVE CHEMICAL
DEFENSE GEAR.
CHEMICAL DEFENSE GEAR.
EVERYTHING IS DEFENSE.
NONE OF IT IS OFFENSE.
HOW CAN REFER TO THE REDLINE
SYRIA UNDER OBAMA AND BIDEN?
THAT WAS A JOKE.
>> Jessica: I LITERALLY SAID
FOREIGN POLICY BLUNDER.
>> Dana: WHAT BIDEN COULD'VE
SAID IS YOU BETTER N